well we kept 1965 flat fingers 88 Empire  those 1974 let the others arrive at  different trainers why can't I because  you're not ready I'm ready dad  unless they don't come off that thanks  Steve  that's a suit  we're gonna find career in the country I  don't want to find career in the bloody  country I'm gonna write great ones I  want to be the best  you're out of your minds get married  good traveling kids - are you telling  your husband's to give up  ever gonna win the Melbourne campaign  the only thing that matters is they  ought to give yourself  did want to see you settle down I'm  happy so okay that I found the one only  makes us  can I do this I know the horse can't  it's gotta be a champion  you found it little girl  [Music]  [Applause]  you  you